une entreprise québécoise a développé un
capteur qui nous indique en autre masque
a perdu de son efficacité et doit être
changée ou laver certains sont amusants
d'autres élégant il y a les artisanaux
les chirurgicaux mais ce que beaucoup
ont en commun c'est qu'il laisse passer
les virus
avec le lavage des mains et la
distanciation physique
le masque est en principe l'une des
meilleures armes contre la copine 19 le
problème c'est qu'on a tendance à le
garder trop longtemps on fait tout ce
genre d'erreurs là c'est à dire de
mettre un masque quelques minutes de le
mettre dans sa poche de le reprendre de
leur maître ou de l'accrocher sur son
rétroviseur
à la longue le masque fini par perdre
son pouvoir filtrant pire il peut
favoriser le passage des virus bio astra
est une petite entreprise montréalaise
spécialisée dans les matériaux
intelligents
elle a mis au point un capteur destiné à
être collés sur les masques il indique à
l'usagé quand il est temps de jeter ou
de le laver
plus spécifiquement le capteur détecte
la présence d'humidité
si quelqu'un à côté de moi à coronavirus
ou n'importe qui d'autre
chris dyer et tous et une gouttelette
bien sûr mon masque si mon masque est
humide est le pouvoir varier n'est plus
assurée puis le virus lui va pouvoir par
migration traversé plusieurs coups de
mon masque les masques les plus
performants comme les masques
chirurgicaux sont composés de trois
couches dans la couche intermédiaire les
fibres sont hissés en suivant des
chemins tortueux pour mieux piéger des
particules
cette couche a souvent des propriétés
électrostatiques qui aimante les virus
poursuivra dès que le masque est humide
le filtre perd ses propriétés
électrostatiques les virus captées sur
les fibres sont alors là j'ai non
seulement ça mais la présence d'humidité
permet de former un pot liquide entre
les faibles
les gouttelettes qui atterrissent sur le
masque fusionne avec son liquide les
virus peuvent le traverser ajoutons que
plus le masque est humide plus le
passage de l'air est difficile et plus
on a tendance aspirait avec force si je
respire plus fort je génère aussi plus
d'aérosols vers moi et donc je vais me
contaminer plus à cause de ces
particules relargués dans mon masque le
capteur de bio astra est composé d'une
encre qui réagit au contact de
gouttelettes ou de la condensation
c'est quand les la condensation et
d'aérosols vont venir sur ce matériau là
ça va être captées redirigé vers l'anc
pour la faire migrer plus on va voir
d'aérosols 2002 de condensation huile
encre va migrer vite loin sur
l'autocollant et quand nos autocollants
et rempli là c'est le signal qui me dit
détente de changer
l'intérêt pour le capteur pourrait se
manifester bien au delà de la pandémie
coved 19 car même les professionnels de
la santé dans le feu de l'action peuvent
oublier de changer leur masque n'est
tous pareils c'est à dire que quand on
est en train d'effectuer des tâches
on n'est pas nécessairement en train de
se demander ce que mon masque et humide
la société bio à ce train est en
négociations avec un important fabricant
de masques chirurgicaux
elle espère lancer son produit sur le
marché dès ce mois de janvier
[Musique]